Imran Khan a cricket star turned
politician is Pakistan's likely next
Prime Minister Khan has used an
anti-corruption platform to build a mass
following but he has hardly gotten to
where he is on his own Khan's main
opponent former Prime Minister Nawaz
Sharif was thrown out of office in 2017
on dubious charges by the Supreme Court
since then he has received a 10-year
prison sentence for corruption and was
arrested along with his daughter and
political heir Maryam Nawaz Sharif Nawaz
Sharif has been a vocal critic of
Pakistan's army many believe that the
army work to throw him out and promote
his preferred candidate in Ron Khan
Khan's use of the army to get elected
does not bode well for Pakistan ailing
democracy his worldview combines
socialism and Islamism he blames America
for Pakistan's terrorist problem
supports fundamentalist positions and
once Pakistan to be an Islamic welfare
state with a struggling economy and
decaying international reputation
pakistan needs introspection imran khan
represents a doubling down on denial
what do you think about imran khan will
he weaken or strengthen pakistan
democracy let us know in your comments
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI